we're entering a new golden age for Star
Wars at least when it comes to movies
but video games though oh boy there's a
bunch of put it away through and because
I'm a sucker for anything with the Star
Wars on it I've played a bunch while
wearing my Jedi bathrobe and drinking
with my color in sippy cup so let me
share with you some of the shooter Star
Wars games I've ever played as I try to
justify my poor decision what better way
to start off this list than with my
first [ __ ] Star Wars game masters of
terrace custody on ps1 after playing
this game on Boxing Day 98 I handed over
99 of my hard earned Christmas dollars
and experienced true deep regret at 11
years old Star Wars masters of Terris
custody is a 3d fighting game similar in
style to taken or Soulcalibur and it's
set between the events of a new hope and
the Empire Strikes Back now let's forget
for a second too many narrative issues
with this game like the fact you can
flatus characters that timeline-wise
don't fit like bounty hunter Leia and
emo Luke or that this game is set after
the destruction of the first Death Star
and yet the end of stage clearly shows a
nearly complete Death Star 2.0 likewise
let's forgive its many technical
shortcomings like slow and erratic
framerate and shocking camera that likes
to prank crush and/or bar and while
we're at it let's not mention the basic
clunky controls the real problem with
masters of Terrace kasi is that it has
some of the worst balancing of any
fighting game I've ever played
Luke control his lightsaber which is
unblockable and hits the heart health
han Solo can shoot first for an insane
amount of damage and Boba Fett can do
this missile barrage thing that just
annoyingly juggles you in the air at
least there couldn't be anything worse
than a stormtrooper blocking a
lightsaber with their fists right right
[Music]
Kinect Star Wars a game that missed the
mark by so many parsecs it was operating
in a galaxy so far away it was likely to
run into the Yuuzhan Vong billed as a
game wherein players assume the role of
a Jedi Master instead it's a collection
of mediocre mini-games
with a star wars on it ever wanted to
dance on Bespin to the Star Wars
universe is equivalent of eat it by
Weird Al Yankovic
or maybe you thought Star Wars Racer in
the arcade was hindered by its reliance
on physical controls for precise turning
and acceleration well this is the
collection of flailing minigames for you
connect Star Wars campaign Jedi destiny
darkside rising costs players is a
Padawan hoping to become a Jedi Knight
in between the events of Episode one in
Episode two initially moving your arms
around to swing your lightsaber and
force push stuff is great fun then
you're sent to Kashyyyk and it all falls
apart groups of droids surround you so
naturally you start attacking them as
quickly as you can
unfortunately the Xbox 360 Kinect can't
keep up with quick movements and you'll
be faced with a choice slow down and
make precise purposeful gestures to play
the game correctly or just play all
around like a maniac can achieve the
same result in the end Kinect Star Wars
was about as well received as the
peripheral it was made for shadows of
the Empire the video game is part of the
shadows of the Empire multimedia project
an idea to tell the story of the events
between the Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi outside of a
conventional motion picture after an
incredible opening level at the Battle
of Hoth this is you taking down 80 80s
in a snow speeder shadows of the Empire
becomes a frustrating third or first
person action game with poor aiming
boring enemies and mediocre level design
throw in an autosave system that results
in you beginning a level again after
falling to the boss and it's a recipe
for broken n64 controllers and the
prequel films seriously shadows of the
Empire is largely credited with
increasing awareness of Star Wars so
Lucas could make the prequels okay it's
time to make the jump to light speed
star wars demolition released on ps1
star wars demolition was made on the
vigilante 8 engine it lets you run
around quarry to the Millennium Falcon
it ran like balls and made me feel like
I've been kicked in them after I spent
another $99 birthday once this time on
destruction derby in space
Star Wars ob1 originally announced for
PC then changed to an xbox exclusive
much to the annoyance of the PC crowd
Star Wars obi-wan had a cool right stick
control scheme for lightsaber control
and not much of anything else much to
the delight of the slighted PC community
super bum bad racing it's a particularly
media
Mario Kart caught with a stobbles on it
again that uses the word spoken by ja ja
Binks in its title
why Star Wars Jedi arena I would like to
point out that I am refraining from
making the joke that this game should
have been called a dick wagon the video
game alright I've got a stop this is
bumming me out and I know I've missed a
bunch so what did you guys some of your
biggest Star Wars regret for your video
game film or even just overpriced
merchandise related and I'll see you
next time there's a bunch of media cuz
stuff to play
you